[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar I have already done the black
Bulls and the magic Knight captain's
rank from weakest to strongest and it
makes sense to top it off with a top 10
strongest characters in black clover
another heavily requested video if you
are loving the black clover content and
want to see more definitely smash that
like button to let me know if you have
it subscribe and this is very important
ring that magic YouTube Bell so you
don't miss any upcoming videos and if
you can't get enough content make sure
to check us out on Instagram and Twitter
at anime uproar for more good times as
always leave suggestions for future
videos you are burning up to see in the
comments and you may see it pop up soon
a lot of you wanted me to make this
video and I was happy to but keep in
mind the author has not given us the
list of the top 10 strongest characters
as a result I used evidence from the
manga and try to rank the characters
accordingly this list isn't definitive
and it may need to change as we get more
information in future chapters but for
now this is my take on the top 10
strongest characters in black clover
spoiler magic lies ahead you've been
warned now let's do this we are already
turning off strong with the elf riah at
number 10 I placed riah higher than the
other members of the 3rd eye namely
meadow and fauna for a variety of
reasons for starters she's still around
while the other two elves have been
taken care of already and in my view
this is not a coincidence riah even
fought against meadow leona one of the
most Opie characters in the series and
he still managed to survive not only
that though because Ryan survived as
long as he did he got fully reincarnated
when this happens in the manga Zora is
shocked by the power boost saying hey is
this some kind of joke as it stands this
guy's monster like magic power has
gotten even more tremendous and quote
the other members of the third eye were
defeated before they could experience
this boost in power which in Ryan's case
allows him to use multiple elements at
the same time this brings us to riah's
Opie magic which is imitation magic as
long as he touched someone's grimoire he
can use their spells he cannot use hasta
Santa magic but other types of magic are
fair game and he has definitely acquired
some amazing spells that he can call
upon at any time
for instance against Matteo Leona hasta
and Zora he uses Yami's dark magic and
Patras light magic at the same time
later on he also combines the insane
speed of light magic with spatial magic
so that he can move around the fighting
arena faster than Sonic the Hedgehog and
just when he has meadow Oh Leona asta
and Zora worrying over what they're
gonna do in El possessed rel and three
other elves show up but the craziest
thing is it is not like Raya was in
desperate need of help
in fact after his for reincarnation he
was dictating the rhythm of the battle
before the elf possessed will arrived
now do I think mineral alone that could
have defeated him if the other five
elves hadn't showed up yes I do
but Ryan's power is nonetheless
demonstrated in this chapter
even Zora who's witnessed Austin's black
formed wonders what are we supposed to
do with this guy meaning riot suggesting
that hasta strengths for the time being
would not be enough to beat him so far
we have seen Rio use light magic dark
magic spatial magic permeation magic
water magic and even fire spirit magic
as he used salamanders breath beyond
this he has the potential to acquire or
collect even more spells pretty much any
spell besides anti magic his spells
aren't necessarily weaker than the
original either since according to the
manga the stolen magic power strength is
converted to his own tremendous magic
power so he usually far surpasses the
power of the original his drawback used
to be that he could only use one type of
spell at a time but now after the full
reincarnation power boost he can use
more imagine permeation magic and light
magic being used at the same time for
instance the possibilities are insane
according to the data book riot
statistics are also fantastic he scored
a 4 out of 5 in physical strength magic
sensing and cleverness and a 5 out of 5
in magic amount magic control and
disruptive power in the end
riah is not only still alive and kicking
he's stronger than ever with access to
some of the most opie spells we've seen
so far and with the potential to acquire
more for these reasons
riah had to make it into this top 10
list in 9th place we have william bond
gence
the
captain of the Golden Dawn squad and the
man who was said to be the top candidate
to be the next wizard king near the
beginning of the series there is no
doubt about it
William is strong his world tree magic
allows him to summon tree roots that he
can control he can create a giant tree
that can trap many enemies within a very
large area the spell just needs time to
absorb surrounding mana to work in
regards to quicker attacks he can throw
a seat at the opponent which will
quickly grow into a tree trapping the
opponent inside the fact of the matter
is we haven't seen William break a sweat
yet so we don't know the extent of his
power and how useful it is in combat
however we do know that he has built a
good enough reputation by the beginning
of the series to be considered the top
wizard King candidate which is no small
feat and that his magic so far has been
impressive in the data book he scored a
3 out of 5 and physical strength a 4 out
of 5 in magic sensing and cleverness and
a 5 out of 5 in magic amount magic
control and charisma for the time being
we haven't seen enough from William to
warrant placing him higher his best
spell that we've seen great mistltein
tree has the significant drawback of
taking a lot of time to work so it
really only works when his allies are
occupying the enemy nevertheless we know
he is strong enough to be the top
candidate to be wizard King at the
beginning of the series even though
strong characters like Fugo Leon and
those L are also trying their best to be
wizard King this suggests that at least
at the beginning of the series
William is stronger than both of them as
we'll see I believe that some other
clover Kingdom citizens are stronger
than William but they would not be
considered top candidates for wizard
King because they have no interest in
being the wizard King so they aren't
actively trying to build their
reputations something that Julius tells
Austin you know they'll have to do if
they hope to be the wizard King will
touch more on that later but for the
time being william rest at 9th place on
this list although this may change as we
get more information about him after
william we got the other dude sharing
his body Patri who goes by his friends
name linked for a while in the series I
can definitely see how people get
confused anyways Patri has his own form
of rare magic which is light magic there
are a few reasons I chose to put Patri
above William first they shared
sophistic except Patri scored one point
higher in physical strength he scored a
4 out of 5 rather than a 3 out of 5 next
Patras like magic along with his 4 leaf
clover grimoire seems no less impressive
than williams world tree magic in fact
from what we've seen so far
like magic looks more useful in combat
light magic gives Patri access to
ridiculous speed to some of the
strongest and most versatile attacks we
have seen and 2 healing powers he also
knows how to use reincarnation magic to
put the souls of the dead into the
bodies of the living giving him access
to strong soldiers then their paw trees
fights in which he used his light magic
to great effect at one point
Patri says that the third eye are the
strongest members of The Midnight Sun
and that they surpassed him in combat
but in reality they cannot rank higher
than him on this list if we look at the
evidence of the manga Yami survives
attacks from the third eye long enough
for Charlotte Jack and those out to come
to the rescue
then these captains were all weaker than
Yami in my view are able to hold them
off in one-on-one fights
none of them loses before the third eye
has to take Patri and get out of there
however Yami was seemingly about to lose
the Patri even though his dark magic is
one of light Magic's weaknesses before
gauche came to the rescue
Patri spell ray of divine punishment was
so powerful that for a second Yami even
thought that Patri had them beat before
Ghosh's mere magic helps reflect the
attack back so gauche actually saved
Yami and allowed them to win the battle
against Patri however Patri suggests
that he lost on purpose when he sees go
she says I couldn't risk hurting you
foreshadowing how gauche was one of the
people that would go on to be possessed
by an elf and elf that was clearly
important to Patri so pocha was not only
able to hold his own against Yami the
strongest captain present he almost had
him too but then he didn't finish him
off because go showed up someone he
could have risk hurting if this weren't
enough to put him above the third high
he also goes on to kill the strongest
mage in the clover Kingdom the wizard
king am i saying that he's stronger than
the wizard king no I'm not the manga
makes it clear that pot she was not
stronger he only won because he
exploited the wizard Kings love the
kingdom and it's pea
he launched an attack called arrows of
judgment which was going to kill the
people of the city and in order to
protect them Julius had to use an
immense amount of magic and focus while
he was distracted Patri gave him the
finishing blow although he's not
stronger than the wizard King Patri does
get points for being able to figure out
a way to kill off such a strong
character he did it while the members of
the third I had trouble defeating or
were defeated by weaker opponents for
all these reasons
Patri has to go above the members of the
third eye and above William as well at
number seven we have the opie undefeated
lioness herself meta Leona Meno Leona is
someone who is stronger than William in
my view but was not considered the top
candidate for wizard King because she is
not interested and hasn't focused as
much on building up her reputation in
fact she spends most of the year in
nature away from the capital she does
this partly because she can eat as much
meat as she wants in nature while in the
capital they have rules against eating
meat it is clear that she is more
powerful than many magic knight captains
and could have always been a magic
knight capped at herself but she didn't
want to be until she decided to fill in
for her brother foo go Leone when he was
in his coma let's mention her
near-perfect statistics she scored a 5
out of 5 in magic amount magic control
courage and physical strength she even
scored higher than fugu Leone in
physical strength since he only scored a
4 out of 5 I wonder if that complicates
the whole you hit like a girl
insult anyways as with other members of
the family metal L&I uses fire magic
remember how Charlotte the captain the
Blue Rose squad was fighting evenly with
Raya
well many old Iona completely overpowers
Raya even after he opens his third eye
meaning that he is stronger than he was
against Charlotte at this point clearly
metal alona is well above simply being
magic night captain level in fact there
is a reason she leads the Royal Knights
chosen from the best magic Knights
across all squads metal dallona is
capable of burning through magic spells
and she was able to do this when Raya
sent a dark magic slash flying at her
she is even able to burn through water
attacks which are supposed to be her
natural weak
this she usually uses her fire magic to
reinforce her already insane physical
strength which allows her to punch out
her opponents Zora is so impressed with
her fighting that he calls her a monster
when he sees her in action watching leo
in a fight is truly one of the best
things about this manga after she
clearly overpowers three-eyed Riya Riya
za reincarnation becomes complete and he
gains even more power than he had before
not only that but four more elves show
up and Leona sends auste and Zora away
so she fights all five on her own one is
a power enhanced self-possessed gril who
has arguably one of the most open types
of magic paint magic and Leona manages
to keep fighting them for much longer
than anyone expected she uses her spell
Kalidas brock 'i'm purgatory where she
uses her own mana and mana zone which
takes mana from the surrounding area and
creates a giant fire explosion this fire
explosion can do devastating damage to
anyone nearby
the attack made the five elves use a
considerable amount of their mana for
protection and even when riot thinks
she's finally lost consciousness she
didn't and even tells riot to hurry up
and come at her although it seems like
she would have been defeated at that
point if Austin Sora hadn't come to the
rescue
the fact that she did as well as she did
for as long as she did against five
powerful reincarnated elves is insane
not once did she question herself or
lose her loveable arrogance in
hand-to-hand combat specifically I'd say
Lowen as the best but I placed the rest
of the people on this list as high as I
did because I felt that they make up for
their weaker hand-to-hand combat skills
in other ways at sixth place we have
Dorothy on swart the captain of the
coral peacock squad tabatha held off on
showing us her magic for a while and it
was definitely worth the wait
Dorothy usually looks to be asleep but
when she opens her eyes she can use her
dream magic the elf who possessed her
body used her dream magic to trap luck
Austell Anessa Charmy Magna and mad
genius ally in a world that she has
control over she can create anything she
wishes but other people's magic
continues to work and other characters
can say stuff to get her to think of
something and bring
into the dream world inadvertently the
dream world is called the magical
dimension and the characters realize
that the only way Dorothy's magic can be
beaten is by figuring out a way to get
outside of this magical dimension as if
it wasn't Opie enough the longer
character spends time in the dream world
the more tired they get which would
obviously affect their ability to fight
at their best if they fall asleep that's
it for them and they will not be able to
wake up in the real world even though
there were so many powerful characters
who could work together in the dream
world they had no chance to tell Sally
use her brains to figure out that they
can get the elf to accidentally think
stuff into the dream world then they get
her to think of the real Dorothy and
eventually the world collapses because
he could not support both of their
dreams so in the end only Dorothy could
defeat her own magic I think that the
real Dorothy would have been even more
of a threat than the elf because she
would have had more practice with using
her power and as a result she has
probably learned strategies to better
counter people's attempts to get into
her head I believe that if Dorothy got
Leona trapped in her dream world
Leona would not have a way of getting
out meanwhile as Leona is getting tired
Dorothy would stay on the offensive
launching the strongest water attacks
imaginable or even summoning copies of
all of the other magic knight captains
for even Julius and sending them to
attack her for these reasons despite how
insanely strong Leona is in the real
world I had to put Dorothy ahead coming
in a fifth place we have the witch queen
it makes sense that the mother of all
witches would rank higher than one of
her daughters Dorothy if we go back to
when Yami first broke into Vanessa's
cage that the witch queen was keeping
her in Yami said that the witch queen is
an opponent he can beat right now Yami
has gotten stronger since then obviously
but the fact that he knew that he
couldn't even try fighting her at that
point shows how strong the witch queen
was even then I'm going to skip over her
unbelievable healing magic and focus on
what she has been capable of doing in a
fight she possesses blood magic she can
create things using this blood magic she
can create weapons like a scythe or even
an execution ground that immediately
traps everyone she wants to trap leaving
them helpless furthermore she can take
control
of people she's cast spells on by
manipulating their blood with the spell
puppets blood she is able to control
hasta after he just unlocked his Opie
black hasta form and he can't resist
despite hasta probably having the most
willpower out of everyone in the show in
theory she could build up a whole army
of Opie soldiers to do her bidding which
would increase her overall strength in
addition to that she can foresee the
future to an extent which can be very
useful for preparing for any battle she
might have to fight how could such a
strong character be defeated luckily
Vanessa happened to unlock the red
thread of fate which literally allowed
her to change destiny
Vanessa's red cat couldn't hurt the
witch queen but he could make it so that
no attacks worked on her friends so
eventually the witch queen decided to
give up trying to take control Vanessa
and kill her friends however if the
witch Queen didn't have a change of
heart and stop the truth is she probably
could have gotten her way
Vanessa's red thread of fate magic
trains a large amount of magic power
while it is active in Vanessa doesn't
have a large amount of magic compared to
the witch queen who scored a perfect 5
out of 5 in magic amount while Vanessa
scored a 3 out of 5
so yeah the witch Queen couldn't get her
way the story had to continue after all
but we shouldn't underestimate her
immense power because of this she could
use her puppets blood spell on Vanessa
and chances are she might be able to use
it on any witch from the witch's forest
even Dorothy we know how much for
control freak she is so it wouldn't
surprise me if she ensured that she
could use that spell on all of her
daughters especially if Vanessa isn't
around to change destiny there are few
who could challenge the Queen next up at
number 4 we got foo go Leon Vermillion
who was the captain of the crimson line
squad before he got put into a coma by
Patri so why is he so high on this list
well a few reasons mainly because things
have changed and now he is out of the
coma and stronger than ever before he
went into the coma I would have said
that marijuana was stronger than foo go
Leon but after getting out of the coma
we find out that foo go Leon now
possesses the fire spirit salamander
which will drastically increase his
already insane magic power even before
going into the coma
poo-goh Leon was strong and Yami said
that the only way fugu Leon could have
been defeated by Patri was if pottery
played dirty
as we know pottery likes doing that and
he could have used the fact that he
shares a body with William bond Jones to
get fugu Leon to let his guard down the
fact that Yami says pottery could have
not defeated Foucault Leon even though
pocha was about to defeat him before
gauche comes to the rescue
shows how much the army respects the
strength of the Crimson lion captain
before he even inherits the fire spirit
salamander before inheriting the spirit
Peugeot Leon scored similar statistics
to his sister medal Leona except he got
an extra point in cleverness while she
got an extra point in physical strength
his stats were as follows a four out of
five and physical strength and magic
sensing and a five out of five in magic
amount magic control cleverness and
sense of justice now that he has
salamander the fire spirit his already
insane magic amount will increase all
the more combine this with the fact that
he has been ranked the smartest of the
magic knight captains and you not only
have an insanely powerful opponent but
also an opponent that could probably
think his way out of difficult
situations like being trapped in
Dorothy's dream world
poo-goh Leon since he is a noble can
potentially hold both the title of
wizard king a title that can
theoretically go to anyone who is strong
enough and king of the clover Kingdom a
title that cannot go to commoners this
is exactly what he aims to accomplish
and given his newfound power I'd say
that he's definitely got a shot at both
now we're getting really high up to the
top three strongest characters in black
clover the bronze medal goes to Yami
suka hero now as we've seen Yami hasn't
always been as strong as he is now like
I said he was about to lose to Patri
before a ghost came to the rescue
however he's improved since then and
he's unlocked his strongest move to date
dark cloak dimensions slash this move
would have been able to cut through
pottery strongest light magic attack it
can cut through dimensions and spatial
magic so normal magic attacks are
definitely no problem for him if they
were to fight now one-on-one Yami would
win which is probably one of the reasons
pottery ran away the latest time Yami
tried
item in the data book Yami scores
whereas follows a 4 out of 5 magic
control magic sensei and cleverness and
the 5 out of 5 in physical strength
magic amount and limits surpassing all
of his 5 out of 5 are extremely
impressive and important to take into
account when considering how strong he
is
not only is he physically the strongest
character in black clover that we've
seen so far even beating out magic less
Boy Wonder
ASSA himself he also has a perfect 5 out
of 5 in magic amount as I've said before
he is the best of both worlds the one
drawback of his opie dark magic is that
it is slow but he's overcome this by
channeling the dark magic into his
katana he is thus able to send
high-speed flashes of dark magic flying
at the enemy then there is his category
of limit surpassing when Yami absolutely
needs to he has a tendency to surpass
his limits something like that is
obviously more useful in a fight than
sense of justice for example he was even
sure that he would have surpassed his
limits when he was fighting the third
eye if the other three magic knight
captains didn't show up and the truth is
he totally might have as was the case
when he unlocked our cloak I mentioned
slash out of necessity
he could have unlocked new magic that
would have helped him deal with the
third eye this potential for surpassing
limits when necessary should be taken
into account when considering how strong
Yami is then there's Yami's knowledge of
key which allows him to perceive and
react quicker to unseen enemy as then
magic sensing could so far unlike fugu
Leon Yami has never been beaten in
battle he either won or it was
interrupted so in anime actuality we've
never seen his ability to surpass his
limits when he has no other choice fail
him so for these reasons I put Yami
above the already mentioned characters
on this list it is inevitable that he'll
grow even stronger but for now I can't
place him any higher on this list
because of the gap between his own
strength at the moment and the strength
of the characters I'm about to mention
the silver medal goes to the wizard king
julius nova chrono let's get his
statistics out of the way first he
scored a 4 out of 5 in physical strength
and magic sensing in a 5 out of 5 in
magic amount magic control cleverness
and forward-looking julius uses ty magic
and
any time we saw him in action he was
significantly ahead of the enemy and
strength but through dirty means Patri
did manage to get him to sacrifice his
own life in exchange for the lives of
the clover citizens in their fight pachi
says it himself
the wizard king is the strongest magic
knight in the land
Julius can restrict the flow of time
accelerated or stop it for a time he is
able to read the near future and adjust
to the upcoming attacks accordingly even
speeding up his own time increasing his
speed this allows him to even dodge some
Apaches like magic attacks which is
impressive because light magic is the
fastest type of magic even when Patri
hits him near the beginning of the fight
Julius is able to use stored up time to
reverse his injury after letting Patri
get that one hit Julius goes on to
completely outclassed Patri Potter even
notices that Julius has strength to
spare and that he is trying to restrain
Pachi without killing him this is a
mistake that Julius should not have made
but he might have wanted to save William
his precious student who shares the same
body as Patri Patri takes advantage of
this and launches an attack on the city
saying even if I can't kill you
I can kill everyone around you thus
Patri admits he is weaker even as he's
found the way to defeat Julius Julius
uses his time magic to reverse Patri
zopi falling swords of light attack and
in the process uses up all his time and
magic power
Patri stops him saying that being the
wizard King as Julius is one weakness
because he has to protect the people of
the kingdom now it seems kind of
ridiculous that Julius didn't finish off
poetry as soon as possible but a similar
thing happened in Naruto as well the
Third Hokage had the chance to stop his
student Orochimaru
earlier on in the series but he let him
go and eventually have to sacrifice his
life in battle against him thus the
teacher at first was unable to bring
himself to kill his own student
similarly I believe that Julius could
not bring himself to kill William along
with Patri because William was his
precious student in unlike Orochimaru
William is portrayed as a good human
being not a detestable villain so it
makes sense why Julius didn't go for the
kill but instead when
for the Captur holding onto the hope
that he'll be able to save his student
ultimately his love for William and the
clover kingdom were his undoing but he
nonetheless proved throughout the fight
that he was stronger than Patri other
characters on this list will probably
surpass him in strength due to time
because they are still alive and will as
a result continue to grow while Julius
cannot improve anymore from the grave
however for the time being he deserves
to place this high on the list before we
get to the number one strongest carrier
in black clover right now let's do an
honorable mention sort of thing you may
have noticed that I didn't include the
first wizard King the demon that the
first was our King defeated or a ca
Silva Noel zopi ma who was supposedly
stronger than Madonna they all would
have made it if I counted them but I
decided not to include any characters
who a passed away before the main story
takes place and B were not brought back
to life with reincarnation magic I
excluded that mainly because there would
be a lot of guesswork involved due to
the lack of info we have about them rest
assured though all three of these
characters were extremely strong and
would have made it on this list if they
were still around when the series began
I also want to give a shout-out to
austell with his black hasta form you
know with his spear die form and even
though well with her valkyrie armor form
in a relatively short period of time
they have all come very far if they keep
growing like this there is no doubt that
these main characters will break into
the top 10 as the series goes on but we
must keep in mind that these guys are
still really young and relatively new to
the game and for the time being I
couldn't place them on this list and now
we have come to the number one strongest
character in the series the gold medal
goes to the real licked licked was the
leader of the elves he activated the
forbidden reincarnation spell that
eventually led to Patri being reborn and
William bond Jesse's body and he also
activated the top-level forbidden magic
that summoned the ancient demon who
could only be stopped by the first
wizard king Lix grimoire had four
clovers and he possessed sword magic in
fact he used to own the swords in the
grimoire that auste uses now recently in
the manga Licht has been brought back to
life
back the diamond Waller sword from
Austin the sword that allows him to
absorb magic attacks and send them
flying back at the opponent we don't
know how much stronger he's gonna get
but so far he has shown that he can
easily be Austin and you know even when
they are in their strongest forms and
working together he appears to be one of
the quickest characters if not the
quickest that we've seen so far in fact
the Corita hasta it's like lick
dissolves into the air it appears where
he wants hasta cannot read his key or
mana for hasta it seems like licked is
integrated into natures mana itself he
is able to absorb you know strong-ass
feared magic spell without a problem he
then sends the magic flying back at them
which is enough to defeat them although
he left his old grimoire and the other
swords with hasta lick takes the demon
dweller sword that he is so skilled with
in fact the lick shows just how much
also has to learn since in theory hasta
could have done everything lick did with
the diamond Waller sword but he was
never able to use it so effectively in
the past the truth is you know and hasta
working together and tried their hardest
couldn't even give like the serious
challenge and he clearly hasn't shown
everything he's got yet not even close
for these reasons I have to put lick at
the top of this list for the time being
and that is it for today's video thank
you so much for watching if you enjoyed
it then make sure to smash that like
button to let me know if you haven't yet
don't forget to join the black Bulls of
YouTube by clicking that subscribe
button and bringing that magic YouTube
Bell feel free to scream like Aastha
while you're doing it for more content
follow us on instagram and twitter at
anime uproar if you want to motivate
yourself to never give up and support
the channel at the same time you can get
our dream big work hard hasta shirt at
anime upper calm link in the description
use the code up for 25 to get 25% off
your purchase don't forget to let me
know what video you would like to see in
the future that my friend is what the
comments section is for remember to kill
your limits and never give up on your
dreams and until next time see us space
cowboy
[Music]
you